hello everyone and welcome to genetics
and genomics virtual event my name is
Karen MIGA I'm an assistant research
scientist at the University of
California and Santa Cruz and today I'll
be presenting on completing the human
genome the progress and challenge of
satellite DNA assembly now for those of
you who are familiar with satellite
DNA's the satellite DNA's are a type of
tandem repeat this is a type of sequence
that I'm showing you here where you have
a stretch of ATC's and G's and a head
detail orientation however unlike the
tandem repeats you find it throughout
the human genome the ones I'm going to
focus on today are found in a head to
tail orientation for millions of aces
and these huge areas of tandem repeats
are typically found to be enriched in
the human genome around the sub telomere
the our DNA and the Perry centric and
centromeric regions which will be the
focus of my talk and these particular
regions because they're so dense and
repeats are absolutely why our assembly
efforts fail in these regions and why
they become the last regions of our
genomes to be completed to reach this
comprehensive telomere to telomere
assemblies now I don't want you to leave
my my talk thinking that satellite DNA's
are just this tandem henna tail repeat
but rather the regions of the genome
that they occupy are pretty specialized
genomic ecosystems for repeats for one
in this thought I'm showing you you have
two very different tandem arrays one can
be orange as I'm showing you here the
other ones in red you also have these
arrays that are interrupted by transpose
equal elements or what I'm calling the
recent tes which are shown in purple and
also the satellite arrays are thought to
be book ended or flanked by the
eccentric transitions that are enriched
for segmental duplications now
understanding the composition and the
organization of these sites are
important not only for just a genomics
view of assembly but also at
understanding their functional roles for
example we know the satellite DNA's are
associated with centromere function and
there are studies that would support the
idea that the composition and the
sequence organization of these sites are
actually driving some of our best models
of how kinetochores assemble and also
how the Perry centric heterochromatin
being organized so getting accurate maps
of these region is really important for
driving fundamental biological questions
forward one important thing to take away
as well is that when you think about
these repeat juncos are these very
unique repeat ecosystems you can think
about the differences not only between
one individual but actually two and we
know that these particular regions are
expected to vary quite considerably in
its moon population as I'm showing you
in this slide you can have individual
one we have a certain size of the orange
array and then an individual too you can
see that particular arrays then expanded
you may have inversions and so all of a
sudden you have a mixture of repeats
that look quite different between two
individuals so it kind of opens a whole
new world of studying sequence variants
that could have function and association
with human disease in centromeric
regions and I want to emphasize that
this sequence variation we've known
about for quite some time and it really
presents an unknown and unexplored
region of the human genome however a
long time ago this used to be a huge
focus for human geneticist and
cytogeneticist where we could see these
types of variations from space here I'm
showing you one heterochromatic allele a
little one versus of those two on
chromosome 9 and previous studies going
back to the late 70s and late 80s and
all the way up to the I already 90s
which would show that these particular
satellite alleles may in fact have a
role in chromosome segregation and an
appointee rates and if we begin to dive
into some of these high-resolution
population data sets and we begin to
study some of the most frequent
satellites that we know exists in the
human genome for example alpha satellite
which I'll talk about later in my talk
as well as human satellites 2 and 3 we
can see that these satellites actually
take up a large proportion of human
genome here on your on my right I guess
in your right as well you can see the
frequency of alpha satellite or the
percentage about the satellite in the
entire genome broken down by the
different populations and the thousand
genome datasets and you see on average
you're looking about 3% of the human
genome is defined by these alpha
satellite repeats and if we start
thinking about human satellites 2 and 3
although we do see a shift towards 2%
the genome there's a tail and so there's
certain individuals that we had
sighs when the genome have a much larger
amount these particular satellite
repeats and so understanding of this
type of variation is very important
moving forward and I would say it's not
only important for understanding just
structural variants that exist in the
human population from the aspect of just
categorizing or finishing the human
genome alone but also like I had
mentioned for understanding how these
regions function may it be through
centromere function as I had mentioned
earlier also how these particular
regions can drive our understanding of
evolution and selection on the
chromosome level since these are sites
that are important for structure as well
as segregation also understanding how to
move into studies of how these sites are
organized not between individuals but
within an individual or within pedigrees
this is the inheritance of somatic
variation and as I had alluded to at the
beginning of my talk these are the last
frontiers for the human genome these are
huge gaps and our assemblies and
therefore understanding the sequence
variants exist in these genomes are
really essential for our attempts to
complete the genome now for those of you
who aren't familiar with the satellite
DNA's and humans centromeres I'm going
to give a brief background human
centuries at least all normal humans
centromeres and the human genome are
defined by alpha satellite this is a 171
base pair repeat that has a wide range
of sequence identity if you had for
example a collection of these repeats in
you were to draw two out at random you
could find that they could have a
percent identity difference with about
60 percent that means you've got a lot
of divergence to play with if you're
looking at my slide and you see four
repeats listed here 1 2 3 & 4 what I'm
trying to indicate is that there's
sufficient nucleotide divergence between
repeat 1 and repeat 2 to tell them apart
and so the challenge here of course is
when we start to see how these highly
divergent monomers or repeat units as
I'm showing you here 1 through 4 or
organizing these multi monomeric repeat
units or what we call as higher-order
repeats these higher-order appeaser
collection of divergent monomeric
repeats have a very narrow range of
percent identity we're talking about 94
and a good day but typically when you
look at the percent identity between
repeats they're closer to 98 to a
hundred percent and this is
absolutely why our attempts to assemble
through these multi Megabass regions
fail and it's not enough to teach
yourself the structure and repeat
organization of one centromere and start
to move into all the other ones in the
human genome for example on chromosome 3
we might have two very different arrays
which I'm labeling here is array B and
array C versus chromosome actually have
a different repeat structure available
Desiree a and even within a single
centromeric region of that particular
tandem repeat has its own set of
variants here I'm trying to show you
once again the higher-order repeat this
time I'm showing you the individual 171
repeat units as circles and you can have
expansions in other words what single
high-order repeat could break off to
make us a truncated copy and that can be
expanded and contracted and you can also
find that within a single array you can
have structural variants such as the
transpose xi switch I introduced earlier
rearrangements that is Braddock
throughout the array as well as
inversions within the array itself and
so what we'd like to do is to take this
model of central organization and try to
develop new computational tools to be
able to study this array study the
arrays themselves and also categorize
the type of variants that are located
within each of the arrays and doing that
I teamed up with so talented scientists
to develop Alpha Centauri which the
github link is here if you'd like to
access it directly and this particular
tool is used to study the patterns of
satellite repeats here I'm just showing
you a kind of a general schematic of how
it works but essentially if you had a
run of tandem repeats you can use a
profiler to characterize repeats that
are similar to one another for example
repeats a b c and d and then you can
look at the distance or the spacing
between these different clustered types
based on sequence identity to predict
the patterns of higher-order repeats now
I've done Alpha Centauri assessments of
a number of error corrected PacBio
datasets here I'm showing you ones is
the gm12878 this is a female
lymphoblastoid line that's from staff
pedigree and on her XO
she has a predominant high order of P
which has 12 of these 171 base pair
monomers and what I'm trying to show you
in the doughnut is that this 12 mer is
the predominant sequence to be within
this individuals array more than 99% of
all the tandem repeats an array appear
to have this particular configuration
when we look at regular patterns
interred in her array and when you start
to look across a panel of individuals we
find that in fact it's true this type of
regularity seems to be quite a central
feature for the X centromere however
when you start to look across other
centromere just may not be the case for
example if we look at centromere 10 we
find that there's a number of these
different high order repeat patterns
seem to be expanding and contracting as
well as centromere 17 and this was
really nice as an internal control
because we had previous literature that
would suggest that there are these types
of higher order repeat sequence
polymorphisms that are expected within
these particular arrays and the repeat
predictions that I was making using
Alpha Centauri actually align with these
types of concordant of previous datasets
in total there are 36 of these common
higher-order repeats that are found in
the human genome they've been able to
characterize here I'm showing you these
repeats broken down once again by their
centromere location as well as their
repeat the predominant canonical repeat
periodicity and you can see instantly
from this particular snapshot that some
of the arrays have a lot more variation
than others and once again there's been
that an extensive amount of previous
analysis of these satellite repeats and
so by digging into GenBank and pulling
out these previously characterized
satellite arrays it's a positive control
I'm here showing you that these
satellite arrays can be very important
were previously shown in the literature
now of course not all of them have been
studied before so I had to go through
and actually do validation to show for
example one array that was fun them I'm
sincere in three which is a Tenma repeat
in fact maps to chromosome 3 by fish I
could show that its periodicity can be
validated by southern also you can study
on how common these particular rays are
so I've been screening through
Koryo diversity panels have showed
they're in fact by common in the human
population and showing that their array
sizes match what I'm expecting these in
thousand genome population match
datasets now once you have extensively
described these types of higher order
and peace in the human population you
can begin to build a database of all the
structural variants that exist within
the arrays here I'm trying to remind you
of the structural variants I introduced
earlier in my talk for example you have
the higher order a repeat which is the
canonical version but you also have
interruptions by transpose by elements
to stone and green inversions which I'm
highlighting in the black box with this
inverted arrows with blue and red and
also these higher order rearrangements
where you have the canonical repeat that
can be rearranged between different
individual monomers now one way you can
begin to show this type of information
is using something called a genome graph
which I'm showing here for example the
higher order repeat on the X chromosome
is known to have 12 of these individual
monomers so you can begin to show all 12
monomers as nodes and the edges between
the monomers to be there by Prime and
three prime orientation or the
directionality between them and because
this is a tandem repeat as you go from
one or one to mom or two all the way to
monomer 12 you find yourself in the head
to tail orientation again so it forms
these types of cycles now all of the
individual nodes have a single
nucleotide database so I've mixed in
with these particular data sets all the
Illumina data that's available for these
PacBio match data sets for example
gm12878 is the aluminum data with a 200
x platinum data sets so I'm able to do
coverage based estimates at copy number
variants within the array as well these
higher order rearrangements for example
if you're going from honor 1/2 and then
it transitions into 9 I can also begin
to study these particular rearrangements
relative to the canonical repeat here
I'm showing that type of rearrangement
in the the graph below where you sieve
monomer to then has a separate edge
which shows about 5% of time going into
this monomer 9 and so then you can begin
to build these exhausts of
to describe the organization within the
array this is also true of inversions
I'm showing you here you can get
high-resolution base pair descriptions
of how these arrays are organized by
mapping precise sites of inversions as
well as the te elements where you can
actually begin to map quite quite
precisely the frequency of tes and and
there insert size and also the potential
for expansion as I'm showing here for
centromere 5 underscore one this is an
array on chromosome 5 where I find that
there is a line one insertion but it's
also expand it out so it seems like it's
taking part of the tandem repeat
description so now once you have this
kind of comprehensive study of satellite
repeat sequences and variants can you
actually use this information to guide
true linear Assemblies of satellite
arrays and the way you can do this in
any number of ways one can use high
quality of those sequences linked reads
but the way I'm going to present today
is using what we call ultra long reads
either the reads that are produced by
the nanopore sequencing platform that
are capable of reaching hundreds of
kilobases in length and the reason why i
was particularly interested in this is
that i was part of a very talented team
that published the first nanopore
sequencing of a human genome back in
2018 and it was at that time that Josh
quickened the Coleman had released their
ultra long protocol on the Menai on
where they showed that you could at that
point reach in 50s of 100 kilobases in
length and by doing so we could begin to
study some of these regions with these
human genomes that we had previously
been left off of our assemblies because
they were too repetitive in addition to
that I had been leading a team to try to
provide the first linear assembly of a
human centromere on the y chromosome the
strategy that we took at that time was
actually using something called back DNA
this is essentially a high molecular
weight DNA typically in the range of two
hundred three hundred kilobases
that are conned into a circular vector
what we designed was this assay of where
we could
linearize the back by cutting at once
and then running it through the nanopore
device and so we could get full-length
free it's down these are
to span the entirety of the insert but
now you have a unique site on either
side of the back insert which I'm trying
to show you in red so you can begin to
anchor and then take weather than
assembly you're just mainly taking the
consensus of these full-length reads we
go through a series of polishing steps
to reach a high-quality consensus
sequence of each of these backs in doing
this we created a protocol that we
released called longboard 1d essentially
it takes
once again the back DNA we linearize it
with this transposon complex we do
ligation with sequencing adapters and
tethering attachment and then we run it
directly at the time for the min I am in
doing so we were able to recapitulate
the entire length of the package what
I'm trying to show you here for this RP
11 6 4 th 18 where we know by postcode
size estimates to be roughly 198 on
kilobases and that's what we're finding
here as well when we start to map the
read length through getting out now
there was previously a study by Topher
Nadal back in 2001 where they had a
collection of nine backs that were known
to span the human Y centromere so we
selected this is our pilot study and we
also focused on the white centromere for
several other reasons not only did we
have kind of this collection of backs
that we knew Maps uniquely to the white
century the Y centromere has a very well
characterized physical map going into
this is a small haploid array so it's
the natural place to start to try to
optimize some of these newer sequencing
technologies and had a very well
characterized 5.8 kilobase repeat and
the goal here is really to sequence the
backs to the highest quality that we
could and then do just overlap layout
assembly using single copy sequence
variants here I'm just trying to show
you our full link sequencing of a
centromere white backs and total we
generated over 3,500 of these rigs that
were greater than 150 kilobases only
here in focusing on one back that was
209 kilobases and this particular back
I'm highlighting the cloning vector is
being inbred and the back insert I
didn't think array and all the tandem
arrays of these Y centromere satellite
the
roughly by poison kilobases been linked
are shown as the blue arrows the single
nucleotide variants which are useful for
assembly are highlighted in purple and
the way that we qualified these
particular variances being single copy
is by looking at the single copy
distribution that we found in the back
sequence for example we did a luminous
resequencing in all of the same backs so
we could build a k-mer based
distribution of the coning vector which
we knew he had a single copy per
experiment and then we could take the
same type of camera based estimates or
cam or depth of the satellite DNA's and
we can identify those camera depths that
match the single copy estimates that we
observed from the back coins actor using
these cameras that we observed to be
single copy we could go through and
create these unique anchors I'm focusing
in now on repeat 30 and repeat 35 of our
assembled array and emphasizing that we
not only had to find evidence of alumina
data to support these were single copy
on one back but all of the backs that we
looked at and they had to be within the
same position of when we looked at the
over about ordering of the packs so now
that you have your predicted array the
important thing is to move into
validation I think this is something
that's incredibly important for
scientists to think about because we
haven't had to actually validate
anything this big the Y assembly as we
mentioned was a little bit easier
because it's one of our smaller arrays
i'mso instant but the problem always
arises with how do you begin to study it
the prediction of your assembly is
correct oh here we took into account
because we're working the back library
which did not have a match style
resource so we found all of the y-hat
quicker it matched males in a thousand
genome data and we found their average
array size to show that the array
assembly that we predicted was in the
right range of what we would expect also
we selected a y haplogroup matched male
and we did post fo gel estimates to show
that in fact our array estimates were
very close to what we would have
expected if we did have a cell line in
this particular individual also I want
to emphasize at the centromeres to find
epigenetically and so in order to define
we are in fact mapping the centromere we
performed sintra protein a which is a
histone variant that's specific for
kinetochore assembly chip seek in this
region to show that yes in fact this
region does bind or it doesn't his
involvement kinetic or assembly and is
defined by the centromere shown here for
the entirety of the array so now that we
had this long read protocol and we also
had a our first kind of prototype of
being able to complete a centromere the
question arose is it possible now to
extend this to complete the entire human
genome this was something I was very
excited about as a satellite DNA
biologists thinking about the potential
I've actually seen a lot of these
satellite DNA's and and they're a multi
mega base view at the same time my
collaborator and co-lead on the
TaylorMade in telomere consortium Adam
Philippi was also motivated to complete
the human genome so this was a very
natural collaboration for us and
together we formed the telomere telomere
consortium now this is a very unique
consortium I hope the audience
appreciates in the fact that it's an
opened community-based effort with the
single goal to generate the first
complete Assembly of the human genome
anyone can join anyone can contribute
and at the end of my talk I'll provide
details about how you can get in touch
now the genome that we decided to focus
on initially was a is a complete hi
gender film all just to give you kind of
a background for those of you don't have
experience with this particular type of
cell line typically when we think about
fertilization we think about having a
maternal genome and a maternal genome
however these particular cells were
derived from an accident where the whole
entire maternal genome was lost and this
either happened before or after
fertilization however the paternal
genome did come into the into the egg
and you had this effective duplication
of the paternal genome so you're now
working with an effectively haploid line
mean it's still 46 chromosomes however
all the chromosomes are expected to be
identical so now you you've bypassed
some of the challenges that you'd have
to work with when you're looking between
maternal and paternal inherited chrome
satellites where they're expected to be
quite different the particular cell line
that we're working with is a heightened
from all cm13
this was a cell line that had been
previously immortalized and established
by a Murshid surgeons I'm showing you
here in addition this particular cell
line had included as a platinum
reference genome by Wash U and
University of Washington so we had the
benefit of packed by ovaries and
Illumina datasets and I had already
constructed a satellite database of to
describe all the satellites in this
particular genome I then reached out and
teamed up with some very talented
scientists to look at the site of
genetics and the structure of these
particular chromosomes to ensure that we
weren't looking at a cell line that was
unstable or had any types of animal ID
and was relieved to find the stage in 13
appeared to be very stable
um and that we found no types of
chromosome instability that would
complicate our analysis and assuming
that it was in fact effectively haploid
but the next question is now that we
have this stable highly qualified line
can we then begin to generate high
coverage of ultramel sequence and try to
put the human genome together and one
might stress that this is really
important at this point to sequence
deeply and that's because even though
you're generating these ultra long data
sets you still have a fraction of reads
that are coming out that are small and
so you have to reach high coverage in
order to reach these really long reads
that are capable of spanning us that
repeat of interest and so we've been
doing this for quite some time we
started back in May and we only recently
in fact um stopped sequencing with the
ultra long siege in 13 at the time when
we were starting to first do our release
to which home we posted and people who
now have access to we were describing 62
of these men ion flow cells roughly 8.9
megabases
million reads or 98 gigs which 1.6 games
per cell blow so that are in 50 were
about 76 kilobases
we have 44 gigs of greater than 100 Kb
and our max length was over a mega base
this is really although we're
emphasizing using these really long
reads this ISM
platform sequencing approach where we
took in every type of sequencing
technology that we could to kind of
emphasize the quality of our final
assembly so now we will be talking about
the nanopore ultra long but we also use
for contact building physics DX
available PacBio data set we also use
Peck bio for polishing we are using 10x
genomics for polishing and bio Nano for
structural variation and validation so
here's a familiar picture from the human
genome of 2001 where I'm showing you a
human karyotype or ideogram or the
black-and-gray are showing the changes
between broken context so as you move
from black to gray you're moving from
different content used this is where we
are today using the canoe assembly on
our we're reaching contact levels now 75
mega bases for ng 50 and this is using
35 X coverage of ultra long data and we
decided to focus on the XS see if we can
complete the assembly at telomere
telomere assembly of a first human
chromosome now the human chromosome by
Ross at all have been previously
characterized to have 14 different sites
that had been unfinished or difficult to
close here I'm showing you the sites
that required at the initial stages
manual gap closure as well as corrected
repeat collapses repeat regions many of
these is you might notice there's
mapping to segmental duplications which
I'm trying to mark her as SD many of
them are actually less than 200
kilobases is we had a fraction of our
return back greater than 200 Kb it's
been possible to anchor uniquely on
either side and then take the consensus
thereby bypassing the need for doing it
these types of repeat assemblies which
can lead to miss assembly or collapse
I'm also trying to demonstrate on the
slide that's giving credit of course a
surrogate Cohen who did a lion's share
of the assembly and also played a big
role and doing all the manual Koecher
and collapse characterization with me as
well we use bio Nano to go through and
try to study
inconsistencies or some of our manual
predictions to begin to to finalize and
to finish some of these regions as well
as we brought in digital droplet PCR to
ballot
some of our copy number estimates for
the tandem repeats now one of our prep
perhaps crowning achievement is its
finishing the Ascension air so not just
a smaller cinch measures we perform for
the why but one of these multi mega base
sized centromeres and to do so we really
took into account this unique structural
variants that are available just for
PacBio as well as unique gamers that
were confirmed by duplex League but I
really want to emphasize that the
assembly is that we're producing a
really a hypothesis and in order to have
something we considered finished or at
rutile I'm ready to more simply takes
validation now the X centromere was a
great place for us to start because I
would argue it provides one of the best
hypotheses we knew a lot just as we did
for the y array we knew a lot about the
repeat class that was defining the
particular x centromere this was
characterized back in 1983 to be a 2 kb
repeat known as the extent one we also
knew from over a decade of work of
Postville gel estimates the range of the
array sizes of this particular repeat
and also this particular centromere had
the most high-resolution genomic and
genetic definition of any human
centromere so it was a natural place to
start and arguably the place for us to
really dive in and see how well we can
perform and doing this type of
complicated assembly and so using this
type of variant overlap that i
introduced for the y array we were able
to predict a 2.8 mega base assembly of
the x centromere i then teamed up with
two very talented scientists best
sullivan and jennifer Curtin who worked
with me to develop a possible gelatin or
chocolate assay to investigate at their
wavelength and composition an
organization of the array what I'm
trying to show you in this slide for
example is that we have postponed gels
southern this is where you isolate the
array and you take a a probe that you
know map specifically to the x-ray to
try to size it as we have size based
estimates for four different lines we
can take the same genomic DNA and
Digital droplet PCR and demonstrate that
we're able to predict the same type of
array link so in black is a possible gel
southern and in gray is the digital
droplet pcr you can probably see by eye
as that you see it's nice concordance II
between the two validation experiments
as CH and 13s at the end we're finding
our predictions are 2.8 mega bases which
is nice because it matched our symbol
prediction as well also we've been
writing through with the postcode gels
to try to on here I'm showing you one
restriction enzyme which is BST to where
we're seeing fragments that are at 1.8
mega base 7 mega bases and 3 mega bases
sorry about 0.7 megan's the point 3 mega
base and that when we actually look for
the same restriction sites within the
array we find once again concordance see
with these estimates as well now the end
of we've been focusing a lot on the
structural variants these are the bigger
variants which of rearrangements and
versions and transpose well elements but
there's also single nucleotide variants
and so in order to capture that
information I've been working closely
with furs in the risk at the University
of Washington here in Seattle to study
the the variants using this high quality
CRISPR cast nine duplex eek where we
designed CRISPR cast nine guides
specifically to the ex centromere right
and began to study the these high
quality repeat variants within the array
as well to help us study and an anchor
more uniquely these long range sequences
so for example now that you have an
entire assembly of an extant ramier you
can break it down into a k-mer map you
can identify which k-mers are now
uniquely mapping or unique signatures
and you can use those unique signatures
to begin to re-enter the long reads to
improve polishing and this work is
ongoing but it's been lent by iran free
from atom Philippe's group but it also
serves as another nice method of
validation because we can begin to study
the reads and how they align these
particular regions for any signatures of
collapse or rearrangements that would
suggested something's wrong with you
right now what are we learning so far
it's been quite interesting as you start
to get into an array that's almost three
mega bases in length the directionality
of the repeats seems very non-random we
find that they go in one direction
without any inversions for the X which
will also matched our PacBio datasets
for this particular genome
position events if you're counting on
that first simply I think that's maybe
not the right place to be because
they're few and far between we only
found evidence for one line when HS and
the X array and conversion can take
place over long distances so some of
these higher-order rearrangements as I
was tracking am I expected to be very
close to one another but in fact some of
them are greater than a Megabass away
but perhaps the what we're going to
learn is yet to come because it's really
by constructing these really high
resolution high quality maps that we can
begin to move into a new world where we
can begin to map epigenetic and
transcriptional information to begin to
study much like what the encode project
try to do more of this type of sin code
or trying to understand functional
relationships between epigenetic
transcriptional and also undermining
genomics now from the beginning of my
talk I emphasized that is insufficient
really to study one human genome because
these regions are known to vary and so
we need to move away from that in order
to study how a study in and tract
steven's variants exist within this
region in the human population as I'm
showing you here once again for a
heterochromatic allele on chromosome one
you can really see these from space we
know they exist and in order to really
track them we're gonna have to move into
a world where we have Moll read
sequencing across multiple individuals
so there's really this new need for high
coverage ultra long reads sequencing in
order to move into a more comprehensive
study of human variants but of course
five genomes seems obtainable - in order
to reach this kind of population for you
we need to really move into hundreds of
individuals and that introduces kind of
a technological bottleneck where we no
longer EADS sequencing is expensive and
time consuming and not only that it
takes into account the compute on the
assembly and and the validation work
that goes into it so we need to be able
to rapidly address that so easy santa
cruz we've been trying to work through
this particular challenge we're testing
moving into long-buried sequencing on
the pro median this is a sequencing
platform offered once again by the
Oxford nanopore it really hit three of
our main
moving forward one is where we wanted to
have the capacity to scale as I
mentioned having these really long
sequences are incredibly useful but we
want to be able to do it for hundreds of
genomes and the nice thing about the
Promethean is that it offers the
capacity to run 48 of these types of
flow cells at once you can really do
laundry sequencing in a parallel manner
also we want comprehensive genome
representation we want these hundred KB
reads to be enriched and so far the
Promethean platform is the only
sequencing platform that's shown the
capacity to actually reach in megabytes
so we emphasized going the Promethean
for the opportunities to be more
comprehensive and finally we're testing
this platform to see if they can have
consistency consistency between runs
consistency and quality and also of its
scalable up to lobby assembly
applications that we have downstream so
our goal was to sequence
11 human reference genomes in 9 days I'm
breaking down the the pie chart here to
give you kind of a feel for how this was
accomplished the biggest chunk of time
was the long read sequencing as well as
base calling we then went to assembly
polishing and then scaffolding here I'm
showing you kind of a pipeline of what
we did we have our sequencing and base
calling being performed in at UC Santa
Cruz and our chromatin we're using the
flip-flop base color we also have in
then we enter into the Amazon Web
service we go into the cloud and we
start doing assembly polishing
scaffolding and of course we're going to
it's not a finished genome until we face
so we're moving into updating this
particular pipeline into a phased
deployed assemblies now I want to
emphasize all of the steps I'm showing
you here we're currently using hengly's
WTB g2 we're polishing using break on
four times with medaka this is the
proposed polishing step from the Oxford
nanopore team as well as scaffolding and
collaboration and Kremes group using
hi-c data and dovetails high-rise
software now I want to emphasize that
all of these components are modules so
as we improve on assembly we approve on
polishing
about scaffolding all of these can be
entered in but essentially we're trying
to get it to where you load the
sequencer and you you have this kind of
really streamlined process to get to a
finished assembly which is what one
needs to have in order to have the
consistency and speed to reach hundreds
of genomes also as I mentioned it's not
only about just the sequencing component
alone we want to have a more
comprehensive looks we needed to have a
sequencing strategy that enriched for
ultra long rates or done calling these
ul reads in doing so we've been using
the standard high molecular weight DNA
prep that was offered from Oxford
nanopore this is something that been
Illustrated for the Khayyam and that's
what I'm showing you cut in this darker
tan region in addition to that we
matched up with Circulo mix and we used
a short read eliminator kit essentially
if you were to include short reads into
the nanopore sequencing platform some of
these smaller readers or sequence
preferentially but if you are able to
decrease them or eliminate them using
this short read Eliminator kit you can
effectively increase the tail of read
links which I'm showing you here and
that's exactly what we found when using
this kit we actually had an enrichment
of hundred KB plus reads and we can
detect that overall when we put our
overall boost of coverage when we
started looking across the individuals
in our study that we would have this
increase now 100 KB reads now for every
individual in our study we have one
genome was sequenced on three flow cells
each flow style use three libraries and
what I'm showing you here is the
combination of those three flow cells
and so for a single individual our
average in 50 was 44 kilobases so I'm
showing you our distribution platform
question and dark blue and things that
are less than 10 KB shown and gray on
your right you can see the overall
coverage for all of the genomes that
we're working with and the total number
of eggs that were able to acquire on
this platform and then the darker
shading what I'm trying to highlight is
the number of 100 KB reads on average
reading about 7.3 X coverage of her
genome that were able to get using the
strategy also we have been evaluating
the read accuracy when we started we
were using
non flip-flop model this is the base
color that's been issued by Oxford
nanopore essentially when we use
flip-flop we're finding that we're in a
mode of 91% type in the native with a
median about 88 but important for us
because we know this base color is
always going to improve we're going to
get better and better is really the
consistency between flow cell replicates
as I mentioned there are three flow
cells per individual and we can begin to
show that we've seen true can sit high
resolution and consistency between runs
which is exactly what we want and we're
scaling up now at the beginning of my
talk I really introduced this Sheila
Meredith Sealy Reuben source Jim that
was once again emphasizing this high
coverage ultra long data set it took us
six months to generate the data that I
showed to you 62 diamond ion flow cells
in total we had 50x coverage within
fifties around seven kilobases and forty
four gigs or 100 KB plus and what the
end of my talk what I'm saying is that
for a single individual now it can take
you four days running on three
Promethean plus tiles you can reach
about 70 X coverage on average with an
infant in 50s about 44 kilobases
and we're looking at about 7x coverage
of Ultron so you can easily imagine how
scaling up the flow cells
you can get the same amount of ultramel
sequence in a very short amount of time
for much less money so we're trying to
optimize to reach the tournament into a
mirror standards but in a more in a way
that can lead to a larger number of
fully resolved diploid genomes so in
doing this i've been taking all of the
diversity information from these
high-resolution Ultron data sets and
building a satellite diversity Atlas
this is once again the same type of
graph based representation that I
introduced in the beginning of my talk
to study satellite array variance and
their frequency across diverse human
genomes this is in collaboration with
the Penn human reference team that we
have at UC Santa Cruz has been
developing a number of Viji tools I'm in
order to build these types of sequence
graphs and our satellite variant map
version one that includes all of 1000
genome data sets and the error corrected
PacBio panels but we also now have these
ultra long data sets or you can begin to
study a panel of diverse deployed
genomes
as well as looking through genomes that
we know are related to one another three
trios or pedigrees the genome and the
Botto datasets and we're now moving into
panels of complete hunted phone moles as
an extension of the telomere to telomere
project so I want to emphasize my
enthusiasm for this being a new era for
satellite DNA genomics I think this is
an exciting place to be and I think that
this is with the goal of reaching these
telomere telomere assemblies it's really
understanding how to traverse and
validate to produce these high-quality
finished maps that will get us to a more
clear and comprehensive understanding of
the human genome and with that I'll go
ahead and thank my collaborators I've
got one slide dedicated to my
collaborators so my colleagues at UC
Santa Cruz the genomics Institute and
particularly David Hassler Benedict
Patton and Mark Dickinson and Ed Greene
Justin Zhuge had in collaboration
contributed towards our NIST analysis of
the genomes fur and a bottle consortiums
in addition I'd like to emphasize our
team rated the team of our team in
particular
Adam Philippi who's my co-lead in the
project and like I mentioned it's time
to finish the human genome and so all of
our data has an open Wrigley's please
check us out online join our group and
we'll be happy to work with you to try
to finish the human genomes and with
that thank you very much for your time
and I'll be happy to take any questions
by email after the talk thank you